hello there I'm Dave Ruben this is the
Ruben report it is October 24th in the
year 2023 we're live streaming on the
rumble on the YouTube on the locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell and for reasons I cannot begin to
explain we do not have a post game show
today just bear with me good people of
the internet we actually going to jump
away today from the Middle East if you
don't mind for just a moment let's just
take a break from the Middle East and
everything going on there and how it's
leaking into everything happening
domestically I want to just jump back
into American politics for a moment
because for the last couple weeks
obviously we've had this massive fight
on the Republican side obviously Matt
Gates LED these uh the seven others
including him eight Republicans who
teamed up with the Democrats to get rid
of Kevin McCarthy Trump backed Speaker
of the House Kevin McCarthy and
basically in the last two weeks the
Republicans have been completely unable
to get anyone across the finish line and
it looks like Jim Jordan who I think
would have made an absolutely excellent
speaker uh will not be Speaker of the
House well I shouldn't say looks like uh
because no it ain't going to happen I
want to show you a little bit about how
the media does their trickery trickery
related to when a good guy uh on the
Republican side is trying to get through
how they try to take him out and uh and
then we've got a Ruben report locals Q a
for you so we're going to do all of that
on the program today before we do let me
talk to you guys about TWC Health guys
want to introduce you to the folks over
at the wellness company and specifically
their medical emergency kit awake
doctors like Dr Peter McCulla started
the wellness company to build a parallel
Health Care system and bring about
change in a corrupt and failing system
part of that change is helping you to
take control of your health and
supporting you through whatever the next
thing is that gets thrown our way most
people don't trust Healthcare right now
in fact over 40% of Americans say they
would avoid a doctor or a hospital
unless it was a catastrophic situation
well that's where the wellness company's
medical emergency kit comes in eight
potentially life-saving medications for
you to keep on hand in times of need
natural disasters supply chain shortages
medical emergencies Etc you can rest
easy knowing that you have emergency
antibiotics antivirals antiparasitics to
help keep you and your family safe the
kit includes a comprehensive guide book
so you never have to guess how much to
take or when to take it if you're like
me and you want to make sure your family
is prepared for the unexpected go to tww
c. rubben and use code Ruben to save 15%
a checkout that's
twc.com is tough because the Republican
party is pretty damn screwy the Democrat
Party is evil I'll grant them that the
Republican party is pretty screwy and
then there's a mainstream media layer
and a cultural layer and a TV
personality layer of protection that the
Democrats get by always taking out all
the good guys who try to get through as
Republicans here is uh do I have to call
him comedian late night comedian here's
a guy who's done blackface many times
Jimmy Kimmel who apparently has a
television show on at night going after
Jim Jordan and uh as you can see well
comedy comedian well just watch anyway
back to Jim Jordan Trump said he would
be confirmed soon but they voted and
Jordan was not confirmed he fell about
20 votes short and they scrapped a
second vote today turns out there's
something about being a loser that
really suits Jim Jordan house is
expected to vote again tomorrow the
Insiders are saying that one of Jordan's
biggest hurdles is that no one likes him
no one in the world likes him and a lot
of Republicans were apparently turned
off by the fact that during their closed
door meeting last week Jordan told his
colleague Steve scalise America wants me
and stormed out the door which I bet
Scarlett Johansson wants you too it's
a I don't think anything funny happened
there they have 20 some odd people
writing for that loser that blackface
loser uh he has been reelected Jim
Jordan been reelected eight times in
Ohio so I don't know about loser but I
guess that's what passes off as comedy
uh let's show you one more from the late
night hosts doing their comedy because
they were very nervous that Jim Jordan
Jim Jordan who by and large is is a
moderate he is painted as a as a crazy
farri Winger and you get how the the
drill goes on that but here's another
late night quote unquote comedian Steven
colar going after uh Jim Jordan and and
largely the GOP fight for the
speaker remember to get elected Jordan
or anyone anyone else would need 2117
votes and that feels nearly impossible
in this fractured caucus as Missouri's
Mark Alfred explained you could put
Jesus Christ up for speaker of the house
and he still wouldn't get 217 well
that's true the modern GOP would never
vote for Jesus I mean he was soft on
Samaritans and commanded everyone to
sell their possessions and give the
money to the poor the guy was clearly a
socialist he was worse than a socialist
he was a Christian cut your hair you
hippie put on some pants leave the
sandals back at your YT comrade what is
the reverse of Comedy if you is there a
word for the reverse of comedy tragedy
tragedy I guess that's worse that is
like the black hole of Comedy first off
uh Jesus Christ was not a socialist
Jesus was fighting the power when you're
when you're a socialist you're for
centralized power that actually is what
Jesus was fighting right whether it was
the money changers or it was the Roman
Empire so Jesus was certainly not a
socialist he also wasn't a Christian
right he was aw Jew Jes all right you
got it
anyway do we even need to Conor can you
put up like a little image of what his
Studio looked like there the guy sitting
there with One mic and a and like a
dirty ass sheet behind him the guy's
probably worth 50 million bucks look
what we've done here that's the
difference you see what I'm saying it's
the difference in the quality but okay
let's get to the Democrats it's not just
the late night host they have to lie and
smear and freak you out about everybody
who might care about the Constitution
might care about Law and Order and might
start doing some good things on the
Republican side here is uh a guy who
really wishes his name was Barack Obama
but instead it's Hakeem
Jeff you confident if you would have all
of your people here this weekend to
continue to block Mr Jordan that you
have enough votes every single roll call
vote this weekend we recognize that Jim
Jordan is a clear and present danger to
the American people and we are going to
be here for as long as it takes to end
this National nightmare this National
nightmare so look we're going to get to
signing on gates in a second first off
the idea that Jim Jordan is a clear and
present danger like the guy believes in
the Constitution he's been one of the
best on free speech he's been one of the
best on fighting big Tech uh twice he's
invited me to events to speak to
Congressional Republicans about the
important issues of the day and the
media like I've only seen him to be like
a decent guy he's not an egomaniac like
all of the stuff but he's a clear and
present danger let's let's show you Jim
Jordan himself you you decide if this
sounds like clear and present in danger
kind of stuff my favorite scripture
verse is 2 Timothy
4:7 Paul's the old guy giving advice to
the young guy Timothy and he says fight
the good fight finish the course keep
the faith and I tell folks I love that
verse because of the action in it
because of the word Americans aren't
timid folks they are people of action
and the words in that verse fight finish
keep I think fit the American
Spirit Americans expect their government
government to fight for them they expect
us to finish our work and they expect us
to keep Faith with the principles and
values that made us the greatest nation
ever made us the nation that could go
from the right Brothers to Neil
Armstrong that's what we have to keep in
mind and that's the kind of attitude I
think we got to have the quickest way to
get all this working is to get a speaker
elected that's what I hope we can do
today I'll take your questions well it
did not happen he will not be the
speaker and it's like if you look at the
guy like do you think he's in it for the
show does it look like he's in it for
the show right like he doesn't even wear
a jacket like he's there to work he
usually has his sleeves rolled up that's
like a running joke with him he's there
to work he he would have been an
excellent speaker it's a damn shame it
didn't happen clear and present danger
maybe a clear and present danger to the
Socialist ideas of the Democrats of 2023
but certainly not to the nation but a
little bit from the daily wire on how
the whole thing fell apart uh after
representative Jim Jordan from Ohio
failed to get enough support to win the
speakership in three house floor votes
Republicans have elected to move on GOP
lawmakers voted to drop Jordan as their
nominee in a new secret ballot in a
republican conference meeting on Friday
the tally reported it was 86 to 112 a
new candidate forum is expected to take
place on Monday we need to come together
and figure out who our speakers going to
be I'm going to work as hard as I can to
help that individual so we can go help
the American people Jordan told
reporters after the secret B ballot so
look he's he's taken it in stride I
think he would have made a great speaker
it sounds like Byron Donald's who's from
Southwest Florida here is throwing his
hat in the ring we'll see what happens
but I'm going to show you a video of
Matt gates in a moment Matt Gates right
now and this is exactly what I said go
back to our videos you know what was it
two and a half three weeks ago when Matt
Gates pulled this thing off where he
took eight Republicans and worked with
all of the Democrats to get rid of
McCarthy you may not have liked McCarthy
now now we know Trump backed McCarthy
you may have thought he was too swampy
or whatever I thought he was doing some
good things Thomas Massie we showed you
that video who's the most Libertarian
member of Congress said this was the
most conservative Congress he had ever
been part of you may not have liked
McCarthy but Gates did make a deal with
the devil here and we're starting to see
the details of that now because even if
you agree with Gates right and you
wanted the Republicans to be much better
and of course we would all want the
Republicans to be better and the
Democrats to be better Gates made a deal
with the Democrats and now the
Republican party is left in tatters uh
but but Gates is mostly pissed at the
Republicans who did not all in line with
Jordan and to that end I agree with him
take a
look any comment for the cam
sir the the most popular Republican in
the United States Congress was just
knifed by a secret ballot in a private
meeting in the basement of the capital
it's as swampy as swamp gets and Jim
Jordan deserve better than that all
right well I certainly agree that Jim
Jordan deserved better than that I can't
speak to the truth of it happened in the
basement of the capital or anywhere else
but this was the fear right Gates you
were going to take out a guy who was
doing some good stuff McCarthy right was
I happy with the Ukraine stuff or
whatever but like basically as Massie
said he was this was the most
Conservative Republican Congress that we
have had in a long long time right he
was tighten tightening the belt on some
stuff Gates made the deal with the devil
now it looks like the devil's striking
back and we could end up in a Sit we
could we at this point we could honestly
end up in a situation where the
Democrats will end up with the speaker
even though they don't have the majority
because the whole thing is so inlux so
anyway I wanted to get you caught up on
uh on some of that because yes there are
important things and especially as
Ukraine and Israel and Hamas and Iran
and our border and a whole host of other
issues are going on it's like would it
be nice to have a functioning Congress
right about now yeah I think it would be
all right let's get to a Ruben report
Community Q&A Tom says Dave let's set up
an exclusive Ruben report cruise I think
your fans and supporters would love an
event like that what say you you know I
have not been on a cruise in many years
I used to do standup on cruises years
ago which I always loved Cruise
situations like it's just like a
complete alternate universe with the
biggest most grotesque buffets you've
ever seen and like the shows and the
casinos and then you know you stop at
Port and you jump on the beach for a
little bit that actually does sound like
a fun idea maybe we're going to do a
little digging we're gonna do a little
digging I've been someone nodded at me
uh Carol says if Iran is pulling the
strings why are we dancing around that
we're in big trouble and need to hurry
up and step up I feel like we're just
waiting for something to happen are we
ready to push back are we safe look it
is very obvious that Iran is funding
Hamas but not only funding Hamas funding
Hezbollah uh also they are protecting
the leaders of Hamas in Qatar uh we know
that they're the number one state
sponsor of Terror again you don't have
to care about Israel specifically you
have to look at this from a Global
Perspective we gave them $6
billion and it turned out to be fungible
money fungible money they could spend it
as any any way they wished that they
wanted to and we know in essence that
they spent it on terrorism right uh so a
lot of this is emanating from Iran
there's always the ongoing question
about you know how close they are to not
only a nuclear bomb but the ability to
put it on an intercon Continental
ballistic missile like all of the stuff
I don't I don't know exactly what we do
you know part of the problem right now
is that when we had Donald Trump who by
the way gave us peace Jerusalem Embassy
moved we had all those peace deals in
the Middle East we you know we dropped
the mother of all bombs was that I think
in Afghanistan we did it and everyone
was like oh hell's going to break loose
he did it right at the beginning of his
presidency a little of the like I'm
going to do some stuff right and I carry
a big stick so you better be careful
that keeps bad guys in check then we get
the Democrats we pay Iran the six
billion or we release the fungible funds
we basically have a guy who's just a
vegetable up there no one thinks America
is going to do anything we have this
horrific withdrawal of Afghanistan that
now it looks like some of the weapons
might have been either funded or might
have been either funneled to the war
with Russia and Ukraine or even to Hamas
like it's it's such a freaking mess but
I don't know it's it's it's odd because
they've led us down this this path that
leads us to where we are right now and I
suspect you know it's mostly before my
time I was I was born in 76 uh but I
suspect that the American malays of the
jimie Carter presidency in the late 70s
right until Ronald Reagan's first years
that's what we're feeling right now a
country that kind of is wandering it
doesn't know who it is or what it is or
what it stands for we've we've been
Bolden the bad guys and we've said to
our allies ah we're not so great we're
not so great we're not sure we want to
want to be the leader of the world so I
don't know exactly what we do I I
suspect if we had Trump or disantis or a
competent Republican the messaging would
be stronger I mean right now remember 10
American hostages at least are still
being held by Hamas okay how is it that
Joe Biden has not given a speech and
said to Qatar you have the leadership of
Hamas in your country right we know
where they are we know what hotel
they're at they're all billionaires
somehow like if you do not release them
all hell is going to break loose it
doesn't mean that you want to instigate
World War III but you you start
threatening people so that we get our
Americans back but we won't even do that
isn't that weird uh Shakur says my
husband and I have wondered how you met
Jordan Peterson and how your travels
with him came to be well you I met
Jordan really thanks to you guys because
this was gosh this a long time ago now
it's about early 2016 if I'm not
mistaken uh no no I remember the first
time I interviewed him if I'm not
mistaken I believe it was the first week
of November in 2016 we had just moved
into uh the first house we ever owned
where we built the original Reuben
report Studio we didn't even have a
studio yet our interview our internet
was wonky but all my audience was
messaging me you got to talk to this guy
Jordan Peters and he's talking about
Peter Pan and all this stuff but and
he's interesting and I interview him on
Skype it's still up you could find it
November of 2016 it's very choppy you
could see it's going in and out he
starts crying at one point we do this
whole interview we finish that interview
I swear to you I said to David who was
the producer at the time I I turned to
him and I said that that guy was either
the the most incredibly genius person
I've ever spoke to or completely insane
now obviously I I think he's the most
incredibly genius and thoughtful and in
many ways I think he's actually a modern
Prophet if we're I believe that prophets
of the Bible exists or that there are
prophets people that their message is
prophetic Beyond you know it's
Transcendent Beyond just the simple
stuff we're all doing um I think he is
one of those people uh how I ended up on
tour with him was I think it might still
be our most viewed video ever I did an
interview one afternoon in LA with him
and uh Ben Shapiro and we were talking
about religion and wokeness I don't even
know if it was called wokeness at the
time all of the stuff and Jordan was
doing his first tour show that that
night they hadn't even set up a tour
actually it was just a one-off could he
sell out a theater and just see what
happened and it was at the Orum in LA
and Jordan was walking out of my house
we did about two hours with Ben and
Jordan was literally at the door walking
out and I said hey Jordan just and it
was just off the top of my head I was
like hey if you want me to come tonight
I'll crack a couple jokes about lobsters
and some of the things you talk about
and warm up the crowd for you and
without even there was no pause he was
like he was like yeah of course and I
went and I crushed it that night and the
Agents were there because they were all
trying to see like could Jordan
replicate this thing does this thing
have legs and a tour behind it and it
was sold out and everything else and
right then and there these were not my
agents they were his they said hey you
want to join Jordan on tour we think
we're going to put something together
and two months later we kicked off the
tour at the Beacon Theater in New York
City which was a theater I had wanted to
perform in my entire life because it was
right where I lived on the upper west
and it was a legendary theater and we
did 100 120 shows in 20 some OD
countries it was it was unbelievable
Mitchell says any idea of how many
adolescents and adults truly suffer from
gender dysphoria I'm starting to think
that 90% of these trans individuals are
just adults lacking any maturity and
running around playing make believe you
know I would recommend you read Abigail
shri's book um Not An Inconvenient Truth
that that's Al Gore's book um hold on I
got it what is
it what irreversible damage than Not An
Inconvenient Truth is something else
don't read that book irreversible damage
by Abigail shrier who's been on the show
and she's a good friend of mine uh what
she talks about is the social contagion
element of this which is why it affects
young girls transitioning to boys more
than boys transitioning to girls girls
are going through puberty a little bit
differently they might not all be into
Barbie and all of the girly stuff and
then and now Society has pushed on them
oh you must be a boy and then we see
this trickle up not only into uh through
Junior High and high school but now into
colleges and we're seeing it with adults
and you know adult men that have lived
their whole lives that are fathers and
everything else that suddenly are
putting not address and demanding you
call them their proper pronouns it is
not to say that there isn't that
0.1% of people who who truly after all
of the the psychological work one could
do truly believe they are in their
different body and and even
if even if it was a 20-year-old who was
confused to a degree but just wished to
live their life dressing in the opposite
clothes and all that if they treated me
with respect I would treat them with
respect but that is not to say that you
have to then you have to then bow to
their inability to um to acknowledge
what real biology is that's why I would
say somebody like Blair white uh who is
a a trans female meaning I can call her
a she because I've had dinner with her
and she's respectful and decent and all
of those things so I will use the
pronoun that that she in this case would
prefer because she wouldn't ask me to
deny biology she would fully admit that
she that she was a biological male I
know it all it all sounds sort of nutty
to some extent uh but this this is where
we have to have there are realities and
then there are how you are going to
treat people and and those things can be
Divergent at times and yes there is a
huge social uh contagion element to this
Stacy Says are you going to Jordan
Peterson's art Conference next week yes
I am it is in London I I have to be
totally honest with you I'm not thrilled
to be going to London in light of just
the protests and what seems to be a
really kind of lack of um it doesn't
feel like London to me when I see these
things um but I am super excited like so
many of the old gang are getting
together uh so many of the people that
you have seen on this show Old Friends
new friends like I don't even have to go
through the list and we're going to do a
bunch of shows from there I think we
have six hours of studio time if I'm not
mistaken and uh first there's there's
about a thousand people it's invite only
for a three-day conference so that's not
open to the public and we're going to be
talking about everything like experts
and politicians and lecturers and
authors talking about climate talking
about economics talking about social
media talking about Free Speech all day
long events some dinners at night and
then the the last day which if I'm not
mistaken is November 1st there's a
public amend I think it's sold out
already right at the at the O2 which is
a legendary uh legendary venue in London
uh where Jordan and Douglas Murray and I
think Jonathan Pou maybe one or two
other people will be doing a talk but
yes I will be there bolo says will you
invite Gad sad back on soon to discuss
current events yes scad is welcome
anytime and actually you know he's from
Lebanon his parents incredible life
story this guy his parents were
kidnapped by Palestinian terrorists in
the in the mid 70s in Lebanon he
eventually made his way to Canada he has
been such a good Fighter for the for the
right ideas and and talks a lot about
the idea pathogens that have led to so
much of the crumble of the West uh
speaking of GAD sad we just had uh
brigit Gabriel I just taped an interview
with her she's also uh he's a Jew from
Lebanon yes they existed at one time not
anymore she's a Christian from Lebanon
whose family was also attacked by
Palestinian terrorists uh we just
interviewed her I've had her on once or
twice before she's just absolutely
wonderful so we'll get that up in the
next day or two and then yes I will talk
to Gad we will have him back on uh John
says I get it there's a lot to criticize
Trump for but what are your criticisms
if any about the santis well first off I
just think it's clear in the last couple
weeks I have completely laid off Trump
because I think that there are way
bigger problems I have no problem
crediting Trump on any of the good
things that he did when he was president
of which there were a lot related to the
economy and foreign policy and as I said
those all the peace deals and and the
rest of it um I think his behavior in
this primary and I get it that's just
politics with what he has done to turn
seemingly so many people who who know
that disantis is the best governor in
the nation seemingly turn them against
him I think has been uh dishonest let's
say um but as far as criticisms of
disantis I mean I guess I have I guess I
would say I have two criticisms of
DeSantis which are things that I've
discussed before like he's unbelievably
good at policy but seems to maybe be
missing a little bit of that X Factor
whatever that thing is that like just
makes you turn your head when the guy
walks into a room like whether I think
that's important or not whether I want
that from a leader or not a certain set
of people are are viewing this in a like
who's the biggest star lens and and it's
it's sort of like he doesn't fully have
that that's not even a I guess that's
not even a criticism because it's not a
criticism for me I want a mature leader
who who is you know forthright and does
what he says he's going to do and moves
on to the next thing so I guess that's
not much of a criticism
um you know personally I disagree with
his six week thing on abortion I I think
the the 12 or 15 week thing we had 15
here in Florida I think 12 would be fine
for for even a largely Red State and
then you just leave it up to the people
but he has a belief I mean again this
isn't a criticism because I can defend
his his beliefs his personal belief as a
Catholic was the heartbeat thing that's
more of a disagreement but if I saw him
let's put it this way if I saw him
endlessly lying tomorrow you know every
time I show a clip of him it's that
thing where I'm just like oh yeah it's
true so it's easy right it's not that I
don't have to contort myself to explain
it do you guys have anything like I I
don't want to I don't want to sit here
like I'm being so
like yeah I'm open to it if you guys
have them I'm open to it really uh Pratt
well I guess I guess something would be
that because if I don't believe the oh I
can make another qualification I don't
really believe the polls either I think
something really different is happening
especially in Iowa he's drawing huge
crowds going all night 99 States or 99
counties um but if we're to believe the
polls then the campaign hasn't done that
well in which case maybe he should have
done some things differently so we'll
see uh PR says do you think the latest
step in censorship in regulating
podcasts in Canada will affect you so if
you guys haven't heard about this they
have been pushing this for quite some
time for about a year uh the Canadian
Parliament has been pushing this thing
where podcasters and I do think we
covered this once or twice will have to
register all online journalists talkers
basically Viva fry asra lant over at
Rebel plenty of good people up in up in
Canada um will have to register with the
government and then once you register
with the government or get a license
from the government you can be taken out
by the government I don't know that it
will affect us we we're registered as a
business here in Florida I don't know
how that could happen could Canada put
pressure on YouTube and Spotify and some
of the other platforms to to silence
people in their country who they don't
like even if they're broadcasting
outside of their country I suppose they
could um but it's it's really dangerous
and if if you care about Free Speech
especially if you're outspoken about it
I I don't know how you could be living
in Canada right now again you there is
something happening in the world you
have an opportunity to figure out where
you want to live and how to live with
people that are like-minded and that you
feel like you can build a prosperous
future around Canada seems very very
shaky at best a lot of the Western
European nations seem shaky at best
Eastern Europe Poland Hungary don't seem
that way certain States in Florida
certain States in Florida I just LED too
much we're going to have a Florida take
over America in a couple years I wasn't
supposed to say that certain states in
the United States like Florida and Texas
are doing all right and uh you have to
make decisions for yourself Harry says
will you be at the RNC debate in Miami I
will be at the RNC debate in Miami uh we
will definitely be doing a postgame for
sure probably a pregame before that
we're going to try to get a couple of
the candidates it's unclear who I know
that uh DeSantis obviously and Nikki
Haley and VC have qualified unclear
about Pence and Scott and a couple of
the others so so we'll see about that
what about Bergstrom my man bergam with
the bad leg he's
out I was pulling for bergam with those
eyebrows now they can study his eyebrows
the way they they were supposed to um
yes and we'll hopefully do a pregame
maybe we can do some other stuff um stay
tuned on that we'll see maybe we could
do a locals Meetup of depending on
scheduling and that kind of thing presy
says do you think it was a good decision
for Governor Dan santis to accept the
debate with lizard man Gavin Newsome I
think it's a good thing however there
are people saying that it was a mistake
because he should be focusing on the
primaries no I absolutely think it was a
good thing the thing that I just
referenced about Dan santis where he
needs that X Factor thing he needs
something because it's not policy there
is nobody even even the most Maga I'm in
it forever with Trump person nobody
honestly believes Des santis is not good
on policy they they might be giving him
over coid right because Trump is
but nobody truly believes I really don't
think so I really really don't think so
at least no serious person uh but what
Dan santis needs is something xfactory
he needs something zeitgeisty the way
that RFK Jr has kind of captured some of
the Zeitgeist right because he's a
Democrat who left the Democrat Party now
it captures something the way that Trump
has Zeitgeist right the government's
coming after him it captures Zeitgeist
he's a media guy D santis has all of the
right policies he has the right
biography you know in the military
lawyer beautiful wife family young three
kids like was a college baseball player
he has all the stuff and the policies
but he's missing the Zeitgeist piece and
and in many ways the fight that America
is having right now or should have or or
will have maybe that's the best way to
put it is the fight of is our future
Florida Freedom Law and Order low taxes
uh safe cities or is it California big
government giant spending you know drugs
everywhere open borders blah blah blah
so for him to just
frame it my vision for the future the
Communist lizard person vision of the
future I think it will really help him I
also think you know one of the things he
suffers from is that because we live in
this Cult of Personality society when he
just gets up there and just says the
right thing people don't just mash the
retweet button right because they're
like oh that that was nice what what's
next did did a trans person punch a uh
punch a dog and he needs a little of
that he needs a little trans person
punching a dog and I think that that
could happen how was
that Connor just shook his head no Dave
what are you doing with your life hey
says what is a perfect immigration
policy in America look like to you first
off you have to close the border now no
more of this
that I said s twice I said I
said poop in the more offensive way
twice I've been trying to control it uh
you have to close the border we either
have a country or we don't that's a
trump line I totally agree with it we
have we have no idea who's in this
country we have to close the border
that's not racist or anything else it's
the it's the sole purpose of a nation
state you look at a map there's lines on
a map right it delineates who's Canadian
and who's American who's Mexican and and
who's from Brazil and blah blah blah
blah blah that's what the lines are on
the map right that's how you know you
have different countries that's the
whole point of a Nation you have to
close a border you have to figure out
who is here and then you can have some
conversations about some people who have
been here for a long time and are and
have jobs and families and whatever and
I don't think you have to deport
everybody but you probably do have to
deport a lot of people you probably do
have to and you have to figure out who
who is here that has American values
like it's a lot of work it's really
really complex I also think that the
next version of all of this especially
if we if Biden becomes president again
or we get Democrat president even if
it's not Biden is that then I think at
that point we can all just kind of wash
our hands and be like all right the
border is open let's just know what the
Democrats are doing The Border's open
and then the states will have to make
some decision Visions like Florida
basically would have to say okay we've
got you know this border with Georgia
here like are you allowed to just
endlessly come and go can anyone just
wander on in because you know Florida is
in an interesting spot because we got
three borders basically you know east
west and south are are water so you have
a coast guard you can make sure people
don't come um but you do have a land
border and the states are going to have
to say we we will protect our borders if
the if the United States federal
government is in total
negligence uh or dereliction of their
Duty then we're going to have to do
what's right for our states and some
states will do it and some states won't
but it should not be that way uh Stephen
with an important question Shake Shack
Five Guys or Inn out it's definitely in
and- out for me for you guys too what do
you Brock what do you got five all right
you're a five is it for burger or total
is it for burger or total that's a very
important question so I will ConEd that
the Five Guys fries are not great I
often don't get I'm sorry that the
In-N-Out fries are not great I of yeah
so what you want for your
totality you're saying totality like do
you have to add in like how much it cost
besides I would probably go in and out
as a whole but Burger specifically Five
Guys Brock in and out as a hole Five
Guys in totality Phenix same same exact
thing wow Phoenix going the Brock route
Connor in and out in and out I need a
salt packet for the fries with a extra
salt packet for the fries I it's the one
thing I miss from C we do not have in
and out here yeah I find Shake Shack a
little greasy that bottom bun is just
filled with grease can I tell you why M
but there's also a a burger element to
this uh Shelly I have a theory for why
Trump won't debate I think it's because
he's looking and acting his age now and
he doesn't want people to see him
interact with others who are quicker on
their feet and don't look so old they
say it's because he's so far ahead in
the polls but I remember Trump as always
willing to B to debate anyone at any
time what's your opinion I think there's
some validity to that for sure he does
not seem as sharp in these debate in in
these talks that he's giving right he's
not doing that many ralles but when he's
up there it's a little more rambly his
his voice inflection it's a little it
does it just doesn't seem a sharp and
also he's angry and by the way some of
that is righteous indignation which is
absolutely deserved but it used to be
funnier that's what people were tuning
in and tuning in for anger is a
different thing but I think you're right
you know he looks a little more and
again he's been through some stuff so I
don't I don't begrudge him that um but I
think the juxa position of him and Dan
santis you know and it's like let's and
Dan santis would keep it on policy here
is what I will do here is what I have
done do you have any he would look at
the camera I mean DeSantis is quite good
at that do you have any reason to think
that I'm lying to you about any of those
things look at my track record Donald
here are the things you did not do and
and Trump because it's more rambly and
whatever you put that against Biden on a
debate stage and by the way Biden is not
going to be debating anyone for sure
they will figure out a way out of this
which is why Trump set a bad precedent
here oh we don't I don't have to debate
in primaries and Biden if it's Biden
will just say well you know what he's a
magga extremist and I don't have to
debate him and we will just have no
debates anymore and there will be no
Battle of ideas and and that ultimately
is not good for a healthy democracy but
I do think there is something to that I
don't think this is purely pulse
although I will say that Trump and this
is where Trump is good in terms of PR
and everything he created I think what
is largely an illusion related to these
poll polls he is not up by 50 points
I've been looking at the internals on
these polls look at them yourself don't
take my word for it they're usually 500
people maybe a thousand people like I
think things are going to be very
different than what we think uh once
people start voting and I could be wrong
obviously but Trump created this
incredible illusion I found a couple
polls a couple polls say I'm crushing it
I'm not even going to debate and then
everyone's like oh my God he's up by so
much he's not even going to debate so it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy I
would I would credit Trump with that
tactic and I would say D santis if we
could get back to that earlier question
needs to figure out a way to counter
that because he's he's the legitimate
Contender right there's one guy drawn
crowds besides Trump it's him and we
shall see what happens wow look at us
doing a straightup political show with
some hamburger talk and a little other
stuff hot diggity dog and we ended with
a hot dog there we go rumble.com rubben
report if you have not subscribed and as
I said there's no postgame show today I
got a couple things to do uh but I thank
you guys for watching and we will see
you soon
am